guck mal wenn du club benötigt man
ehrlich wenn du gut aber wir sind beide
drin hallo und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde aßlar games zusammen mit
imre winzer hallo guten tag liebe
freunde wir spielen heute zusammen auf
ausländische art und weise die survival
games oder auch zu deutsch die
überlebens spiele das wir zum spaß
machen es wird richtig spaßig ich freue
mich auch schon auf die player versus
player also spieler versus versus
spieler spieler gegen spieler das
verpennt beruf in deinen kopf drin sind
steine darin
ich bin ein richtiger blöde blödmann
diese serie siri wann wird denn diese
serie kommen ja also die wird jeden
dienstag
sie kommt kräftig auf einem kanal für
uns allerdings nicht sehr gerne in dem
herbe tipps für eine höhere marge im
berliner maritim über das gerät und
immer wenn wir in der arena drittel an
unsere sprache wir werden vom sony
dienst
mein bizeps es so heftig gewachsen seit
ich hoffe sehr groß okay thema dieses
denken
ich hab nur noch halbe leben der brüder
wright
du musst auf masten trainieren wie hieß
es du kommst du mal wenn du club gießen
aber er ist nicht das tier die runde zu
gewinnen sondern einfach herr bei euch
zu helfen
im jährlich in den in den themen die wir
machen in den mund drin zu stehen die in
der moderne erhält gesagt letztes mal
was ganz wichtig wenn ihr studium geht
richtig wichtig nicht immer ganz viel
gewicht nehmen so dass es schon anfang
weh tut und dann aber nur drei
wiederholungen machen das beste das
beste wenn ihr in dem studio geht und
ihr macht euch nur die haare in den
spiegel drin
das verstehen alle berufe am besten
muskel und kommt im studio und geht
spiegelt das vorspiel gemacht zu müssen
und punkte das herstellen besten ins
stadion
ich hab ich ja als ich hätte das
bestreben tiere lambrü die unter knapp
mannschaft letztmals schon viermal
getötet aber es hat mir immer schmerzen
mein herz drin
ich mache das nicht mehr
ich glaub ich nicht laufen
keiner will sich mit einer freundin da
war nichts drin so wie in der kiste
damit ihr bei dem thema dranbleiben
es war so ruhig war es in die studie
drin und es war ein meditativer tanz
hübsch lass mich ausreden und ich hab
sie es ich hab die langhantel genommen
sie waren so schwer wie ein phaeton und
verletzten sie links drin
ich habe schon drei mal gesagt aber sie
war immer noch selbst
vielleicht ist sie mittlerweile tot aber
ich weiß nicht ich hab mir genommen hat
habe so schwer wie altertum lok auf die
1000 kilo war ich hab zwei genommen ich
habe zwei genommen ich habe zweifel
thomas genommen
jedenfalls dann ich hab nichts geschafft
ich habe gemacht hat weiß nicht bunter
war was los vielleicht 17 mal und also
und dann dieser zugeguckt geschafft den
millionen direkt alter direkt mit 40
kilo mehr 40 milan habe ich da drauf
gepackt 40 millionen euro
ich war letztes mit drei bmw im 6er bmw
mit meinem 30
ich bin hier und ich sagte wir nicht
richtig trainieren
zur bibel ich habe sie der wirklichkeit
ich hatte alle extrem es gibt auch den
wettlauf direkt rinne zu pflegen gedeckt
zum bergsteigen für mutter bot ich höre
das gemerkt mit cbc 110 jährigen
gesprochen würde den markt so was du
warst halt im pumpwerk ich höre ich habe
adrenalin nicht höre ich wenn ich
bereits er hat kein herz wenn er die
städte denn du so mit den anderen dingen
und du weißt du willst mir erst kein
trainingskollege bruder ich würde dafür
dass der turm eine police effekte die
jungs müssen die märkte werden
das heißt zusammen sonst auch seinen
namen auf jeden fall ne und ich höre
dass auf jeden fall die erste kundin und
nächste mal ihr könnt auswählen ob es um
frauen oder autos gegen ende hin von dem
server herunter damit vernünftig aber
bedingt durch
ich würde die engere und ich also der
markt mit dem ergebnis vom leben die
leute ich bin jetzt darunter das ja
genau ich hoffe es hat wenig spaß
bereitet mal auf einen kleinen
blickwinkel in die in solche seiten
unseres körpers deutsche kultur zu
bekommen hat dann mag ich freuen und
wenn du mehr ackern soll dann das haltet
einfach immer dann wollen wir dann immer
hochladen
ich habe daran gedacht dass wir jetzt
ausnahmsweise mal mit aus hochladen aber
sonst immer dienstags regelmäßig oder
auch mal dass gerade videos der dienstag
allerdings kommt die beim rewe erst
morgen mittwoch da könnte mal ausrichten
die ganzen p 3
pd trieren durch durch den dichten als
er durchgesetzt hat genau der song klar
dass haltiner den dienstag und das ist
dann dienstag ist anna-maria sagt games
ja gut dann würde ich ihr könnt noch ihr
könnt auch schreiben erweckt welche
themen möchtest du das mal anspreche
genau wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr uns
sagen welche themen gehören wollen weil
wir haben nämlich uns richtig informiert
und haben ganz viele bibliotheken
durchkämmt um für euch spannende und
anspruchsvolle themen zu finden
aber bitte schreibt nichts was über sex
weil davon haben wir noch keine ahnung
wer noch keinen sex hatten
dann wünsche ich euch noch einen schönen
tag und tag macht eure hausaufgaben